どっちかで最近ものを買いすぎてそっちでどっちかわかんねえんだよ多分こっちだと
思う
まあこれがもう片方の段ボールには何が入っているのだろうか
気になりすぎて寝れない日々が1週間続いたよはいね今までこちら cl 魔球昼間9
と書いてあるんです
こちらどんなものかといいますとロール型投擲消火用具でございます地元近くに投げて
もうなんか投げるだけ
正垣より簡単ず早くしょっか投げやすい後片付けば学級2ペアの夏場はよく火を使う
場面が多いと思います花火やバーベキューやなぁ
2つしかね色んなと思うんだがもう日常生活で分夏じゃなくてもいいよ1番その一つが
危ないんですよね矢部ないんですけどもなんか消化器頭が動いてるんですけども消化器
を使うのって実際多分難しい使ったことがない方も多いと思うので音がこちらの教える
まっ9巻前みたいな日がを着せればに投げるとそれだけでしょうかができるという
すごいすごい
いうものだシーでそれにしても舐めたカラーリングですなもうこんな感じで数が起きて
てももうここで受けてポイッと投げからする火が消えるみたいな
すごい hots ラン今からバーベキューに行くんですけどもなんかなんか予想以上
にを得る気がするんですよ
よぞ何も得るキムする普通に化けて僕が楽しみたいんだけどひょっとしたら
歓声を受けるかもしれないこれちょっと高度消える負けを持ってってばービって言って
みようと思いますだってこのカラーリングでそんな効果があるかって思っちゃいますよ
馬鹿ちょっとから本当にまだすんじゃない
今回はこれの意欲というか本当にさんと火を受けているのかって言うと検証していこう
と思います
ねないこ
me
市は本当の俺のおりティックってありがとうございますけど
jabber はずが出せそうよ
セミが得るセグば向けて居所
car
c
見えません
スミ持ったと思います農業なくなって語彙やのそのでやる気たんでここだけはありでし
たと思います
てってっにじゃあ環境にも優しいらしいので今回みたいに山田感じになるか一ねそう
味になるか一言も言ってるんですけどやるときも環境に優しいので
大丈夫らしいですが一覧
くださいん
パーティーつはまた機が肉と切手などに聞いても体得か
このセミナー
4日
上げます恋するまでマッサー
だして作っ
スパじゃあまた毛ずライブはで聞こえないけど得ないでっ
処罰&とんでも微笑んのストーンがもやいでしょさせやばいこれは
amaran
投げるだけに居合わせた
ああああああ
ていません
素数
あっあっあったじゃないまたばとこ行ったほうがいいのかな
ん
これはたくないといけません
あっじゃあ
引いてて内側選んで友達ですよ
バサーアーサー1間
迫った10株はれたレシーブ動いてるのかすませないちょっとずれたぞん
自然とか燃えてるよねほんとそうなんですよねまずヤバイってこれからまだ使えるよう
になってる
ゲロ
おっはー
ねまってなんでなんでなんですちょっと消えないのねえ+はもう一あるんですけど気に
かけずに穴がセキュリティをすぎってくださって行ってそれから
います
背景待った
いっしー
すごくぞ
あのアジャパターン